[Music]
[Music]
here in this video we are going to have
a little bit of a review on the new
jurassic world movie dominion it's going
to be a non-spoiler review and we are
just going to speak about what we saw
and what the movie really did in terms
of addressing the long term storyline
the movie as a whole plus the dinosaur
scenes but without revealing the details
of the film
so let's get to it
so what was the movie really about it's
kinda hard to tell in the beginning and
even in the end it didn't really address
the situation like at all i know many of
you who are really fans of the franchise
will have a different opinion to mine
but to be fair i'm also a fan i have
been a dino fan ever since the first
jurassic park movie was released i was
just a kid back then and was super
scared of the t-rex scenes the lost
world was also a good sequel but
jurassic park 3 was kind of a letdown
except for the final spinos scene and it
ran it on caged scenes so yeah that's
the same feeling i had with jurassic
world jurassic world fallen kingdom and
now this there was no spielberg feels at
all more of like a san andreas the rock
kind of thing
to me dominion was really like
the same it lacked luster liked a good
storytelling and there were too many i
don't know unbelievable parts
so to answer the question the movie is
really a mix of liam neeson's taken the
kidnapping theme
um a weird aspect on cloning human
cloning and how it's the answer to
everything monsters let loose on the
planet like godzilla king of the
monsters but it's normalized and yeah
just the basic dinos in a park then
disaster strikes and everything goes
chaotic so basically nothing really new
towards the second half things started
to get a little bit jurassic parky again
and it was kinda good but the ending was
totally insane and not in a good way
so where and when is it set it's here
that i have the most problem with to me
i think that the movie sequences are
stretched too far and thin in between
it was too unbelievable that they could
travel long distances and then play
catch-up
there were two subplots that eventually
converged in the end
there were too many main characters in
the film i like that they brought up the
og ones and then brady claire and maisie
but all in all they didn't really have
enough time to make really that that
much of an impact
but the movie was just too fast and for
a while i was like where are we now
it's like a broken vase repaired with
duct tape and spit
and again there was little to no
character development on the side of the
antagonist heck even the dinosaurs like
for example rexy from the first movie
was a caged up beast that once she
escaped she became a menacing threat and
not just that but also a restorer of the
natural order so the other dinos what
they
were just like playthings no backstory
on the giganotosaurus whatsoever but
they were good looking and there were
also certain scary scenes there were new
species old ones returning back and even
none dinosaurian monsters and even
feathered ones
but all in all they were pretty easy to
avoid
there were a few dino vs dino scenes
that were awesome
but there were others that we expected
to see but didn't really come to be
so the movie starts in the united states
and ends up in a site in europe that i
will not reveal and it's just a few
years of the fallen kingdom well
basically five or six years after
lockwood manor and it's hard to think
that in those few years dinosaurs have
reached as far as japan or australia and
not just the flying ones the terrestrial
carnivores as well
as you have seen in the trailers or the
tv spots these animals are everywhere
and and whatever they did in fallen
kingdom to keep them out of the black
market obviously
failed so what was the point of fallen
kingdom anyway let's just say that it is
kind of like a disaster movie but
without the fear of impending doom even
though they did try to bring that into
the storyline with a certain genetically
enhanced
organism and it kind of set up the
overarching plot to a point
so the question is how does it connect
with the previous movies well it is
supposed to be the grand finale and one
that ties up all loose ends of the
jurassic verse but in reality it just
made a few extra ones
it is definitely a sequel to the other
two jurassic world movies but it didn't
really tell us what happened i mean it
did but it was shallow and just to set
the tone of the current events
believable
like for example we all have seen the
dinos let loose and malta in the
trailers right so it wasn't like the
lost world where it was kind of dark and
dingy and the t-rex was wreaking havoc
it was the complete opposite no
spielberg feelings whatsoever it was
fast unappealing and no fear factor
whatsoever included
remember the interrupter scene where the
hybrid dinosaur was created and trained
to attract and kill people after being
tagged or painted with a laser well hold
on to that thought when you watch the
movie and don't be too hasty to
criticize
cause for a moment there i too looked at
my friend on the side and said why
didn't they just shoot they had guns but
it did come through or it kind of did so
it was kind of good
so was it really just a nostalgic theme
film
yes and no kind of a mix of both of
which there are tons of film spraying on
that certain emotional damage that we
millennials have with our past
ellie sadler alan grant and ian malcolm
had their famous lines spoken and scenes
remade
they were more of a comical relief at
all
at best i mean uh so just don't laugh
when you see a certain steve jobs want
to be in the movie
yeah so why did they even make this
movie at all
to make money i guess and to somehow end
the franchise after milking that dead
cow
anyway
it's up to you to decide
what may come may come i guess some old
philosopher said
so with that we come to the end of this
video hit the like button support us
subscribe
and hit that bell button for regular
updates
till the next one take care fam